مساء الخير ما هو الناتو العربيه هي اهداف
فرص نجاحها الى اثاره اصبحت مهمه بعد ان
اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بشكل رسمي
خلال جولته الاخيره اللي طاف فيها من دول
عربيه في المنطقه لحشد صناع القرار في
الدول اللي لفكره الناتو العربي او
التعبير الادق اللي هو قاله تحالف الشرق
الاوسط التحالف الاستراتيجي للشرق الاوسط
وحدد اهداف هذا التحالف او هذا النيتو
العربي بين مواجهه اخطار الارهاب وخطر
ايران
وقال ان اطرافه هي دول الخليج الست
بالاضافه الى ايران ونصف يبقى فرص نجاح
هذا الناتو العربي او هذا المعسكر او هذا
التحالف اللي بيستهدف الارهاب وايران
علشان نفهم فرص نجاحه لازم نعرف الدول
المتحمسه والدول التي ليست متحمسه او
متردده او لها راي اخر الدوله المتحمسه
نقدر نقول على راسها طبعا الولايات
المتحده و هدف الولايات المتحده من هذا
الناتو او من هذا التحالف بسيط جدا ال
امريكا ترغب فهي تخص بقوتها قدر ما تستطيع
فيه قول المنطقه في كل منطقه الشرق الاوسط
لان جزء من سياستها العامه توجه قوات اكبر
من قواتها الى منطقه جنوب شرق اسيا
لمواجهه الخطر الصيني والروسي
ولما تخفض قوتها يعود تخفض القوات وفي نفس
الوقت تحافظ على مصالحها وتحافظ على
اجندتها في المنطقه وتكون من من بين هذه
الاهداف الرئيسه هي طبعا احت والضغط عليها
ومحاصرتها وفي ظل حكومه يتمنى لو انه
المسائل الان المساله تتجاوز الحصار الى
حرب لان الحرب دي مش تحقق مصالح الولايات
المتحده ولكن بالدرجه الاولى مصالح الرئيس
الامريكي الرئيس المازوم
اللي بيحاول يبحث عن ازمه خارجيه تخرجه من
ازمته الكبيره والمشاكل الداخليه الكثيره
اللي يمكن ان تؤدي الى عزله قبل ان نهايه
فتره ولايته او على الاقل تؤدي الى انتهاء
وتبخر فرصه للترشح لولايه ثانيه في نوفمبر
الفين وعشرين بالنسبه الطرف الثاني او
الدوله الثانيه ال متحمسه جدا لهذا
التحالف وهي الطرف الخفي الحاضر الغائب
اسرائيل اسرائيل تتمنى طبعا قطعا سوف تكون
وان لم يكن اسمها مدرب بشكل رسمي في هذا
التحالف لاسباب مفهومه طبعا عدم اغضاب
الراي العام العربي هي حريصه جدا على دعم
هذا التحالف والمشاركين بشكل قوي من وراء
الكواليس
لاكثر من سبب السبب الاساسي فيهم ان هي
تعتقد ان ايران واحده من العقبات القليله
المتبقيه مش امام استيعابها بس في المنطقه
ولكن هيمنتها على المنطقه وقيادتها يعني
شرق اوسط جديد بقياده اسرائيليه الامر
الثاني وهي سعيده بوجود عدو مشترك بينها
وبين الدول العربيه اعدائها السابقين
بتتمنى انهى تثبت لهم من خلال دورها
الفاعل وقدرات الفاعله في حته وايران
والارهاب لا تثبت للدول العربيه اللي هي
مش عده الصديق وانهى ممكن تبقى مفيده
وليست مصدر للتهديد وتتمنى انها تستغل هذا
الانتماء على مستوى السياسيين والقاده
والعسكريين ان تكون فرصه انها تكون اكثر
قبولا على مستوى شعبي بين الدول العربيه
وبالتالي هي متمسكه بهذه الفرصه اللي مش
بس توفر لها عدو وهمي الى حد كبير
يعني عدو موجود في بعض الدول العربيه وهي
بتخلي وهي اه حريصه على المبالغه في خطر
هي والولايات المتحده لاسباب منها ان يشغل
كل الدول العربيه عنها حليف تقليدي اسف
كعدو تقليدي للدول العربيه ولكن كمان تبقى
فرصه انه هي تبقى اكثر صداقه ويبقى في
علاقات طبيعيه اكثر مع الجيران من خلال
هذا العدو المشترك فيما يتعلق بالبلد
الثالث ال متحمس جدا لهذا التحالف في
الطبعه السعوديه يدي الاسباب مفهوما لانها
تعتبر ايران هي اكبر خطر على امنها القومي
وهناك ازمات اخرى ممكن ان نناقشها في
حلقات قادمه
ويشارك الحماس بالنسبه للسعوديه الى حد
كبير الامارات والبحرين اللي بيعملوا في
هذا من هذا التحالف انه يكون قوه ردع وليس
قوه عنوان لانه لا الامارات ولا البحرين
حكم توقع هم الخرافي وبحكم اه مساحتهم
وبحكم تركيبتهم السكانيه ممكن يتحمله
الدخول في حرب حتى لو تم بالشراكه مع دول
اخرى مع الولايات المتحده و بدعم من
الولايات المتحده اما فيما يتعلق بباقي
دول فيها اه مختلفه الكويت رغم ان هي
بتشوف انه ال ال ال ال ال اه ايران بلد
بيمثل خطر كبير عليها لكن هي حريصه على ان
تشترك او تبادر باي تحالف يكون في عدوان
على ايران لانها تعتقد انه هي ان اي حرب
لقدره ضد ايران وتكون خسائر كبيره جدا
خصوصا بان تجربه العداء بينها وبين العراق
في اواخر الثمانينات والتسعينات ما زالت
مثلا في الاذهان وبالتالي هي لا ترغب في
مساله تظهير اي تحالف يمثل استفزازا
لايران عملا موقفها مختلف واوضح لان هي
متمسكه تماما بمبدا الحياه والوقوف على
مسافه واحده من كل الاطراف وتعتقد ان هي
معندهاش اى مشاكل مع ايران
بل ان ايران يعني احد اسباب قد عاشها
الاقتصادي واحد اسباب اهميتها الدبلوماسيه
لانها تمثل قناه خلفيه للولايات المتحده
ولا بعض دول الخليج ولاسرائيل للتواصل مع
اه ايران وهي لا تشارك في اي قمه عربيه
تعلم سلفا انها سوف تدين ايران فما بالكم
بتحالف يسعى الى اه استهداف ايران قطر على
علاقه بايران فخوره ب علاقتها بايران
وبتتحول تطورها كانت مقطعه او بعد الحصار
اللي تفرضها عليها الرباعي العربي
السعوديه والبحرين والامارات ومصر و
بتحاول ان هي توجه التحالف مكون من ايران
والعراق وتقيم الشريعه من نوع من التوازن
وامام التحالف المحاصرين ثم احنا تكلمنا
في حلقه اخرى عن العلاقات الاقتصاديه اللي
اه اه العمود الفقري فيها هو اه حقل غاز
الشمال اللي موجود في الخليج العربي تصدره
ضخمه جدا للثروه قطر اللي كانوا في قطر
وكانت وفي ايران
وبالتالي مش كل الدول الخليج متفقه على
فكره ان ايران هي العدو اللي يجب التحفظ
عليه والمشاركه في التحالف يستهدفها بشكل
مباشر اما اذا تكلمنا على ال ال اه الاردن
ومصر ف الموقف مختلف ايضا بالاردن بتعتقد
انه رغم انها لا تشعر بالارتياح لايران
لكن هي بتعتقد انه مشكلتها تماما مش مع
ايران مشكلتها مع اسرائيل ومع سياسيه
سياسات الولايات المتحده في المنطقه
اسرائيل اللي بتحاول تصف القضيه
الفلسطينيه بتصفي حل الدولتين دوله يهوديه
دوله فلسطينيه بدعم امريكي بمعنى ايه
بالنسبه للاردن معناه انه الفلسطينيين لن
يقول لهم مكان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله
خصوصا في الضفه الغربيه وطبعا القدس معنى
كده انه في حال نجاح مخطط اسرائيلي اللي
ماشي فيه ومعدلات سريعه في اطار
اما الاسرائيلي اما الفلسطينيين اللي
موجودين في الاراضي المحتله خصوصا في
الضفه حيكون فيه موجه نزوح الى الاردن يا
اما حتى لو ما فيش موجات نزوح للاردن هذا
يعني انه المواطنين الفلسطينيين او
المقيمين الفلسطينيين اللي موجودين في
الاردن يعتبر انهم اصبحوا اصحاب حق دائم
في الاقامه والمواطنه في الاردن وهذا يهدد
اضطرابات كثيره في المملكه ويهدد بالاساس
مستقبل المملكه او الاسره الهاشميه مصر
لها موقف مشابه قد لا تشعر بالارتياح في
للايران بدرجات المتفاوضه يعني قناعات
متفاوته صناع القرار في مصر لكن في كل
الاحوال اكثر ما يمكن ان تقدمه تقديم عليه
مصر هو برود ديبلوماسي اه عداء سياسي لا
اكثر لكن ليس لدى مصر لدى مصر
يساعدها او يشجعها على فكره ان هي اه
تشترك في تحالف يسعى الى استهداف ايران
والدخول في مواجهه عسكريه مع ها هي ممكن
تحاول ان تستفيد تامل في الاستفاده من هذا
التحالف في مساعدتها في مواجهه العدو
الاساسي بالنسبه لها اللي عم الجماعات
الارهابيه سواء في سينا او في ليبيا وليس
العكس وبالتالي ما فيش اتفاق على مساله
الارهاب
اكثر من ايران ليس هناك اتفاق بين هذه
الدول على مفهوم الارهاب ايضا
يعني مثلا هل ان السعوديه
بتعتبر حماس جماعه ارهابيه فيما ان الكويت
قاده الجهود في مجلس الامن في مايو اللي
فات علشان تفشل محاوله الولايات المتحده
لادراك حماس او اعتبار حماس ك مع ارهابيه
وقطر تمول حماس وحتى الخلاف على الارهاب
او مفهوم الارهاب
احيانا بيكون داخل الدوله الواحده يعني
اعتقد ان مصر القضاء المصري يعتبر في حكم
من الارض المصري احمد جماعه ارهابيه لكن
السلطات المصريه
وتستقبل كل هو مفوض من حماس وتقوم بدور
الوسيط الاساسي ما بين حماس وما بين فتح
وبالتالي ما فيش اتفاق بين الدول
الدول الثمانيه اللي ما يكون في وبيعملوا
هم يكونوا نوال للناتو العربي او القوى من
الاساس اللي الناتو العربي ولا في اتفاق
على كذلك الخطر الايراني اكثر من كده فيه
عقبات يعني كبيره جدا وما امام فرص نجاح
هذا الناتو بالاضافه الى عدم الاتفاق او
تباين وجهات النظر في فكره الخلافات بينهم
وبين بعض يعني يعني مثلا هل من ال اه فرص
نجاح نيته اه اه تشترك في دول الخليج اذا
كان هناك قطيعه بين فيه ثلاث دول مجلس
التعاون
اه مجلس التعاون بتحاسب قطر او بصفر او ب
تتهمها
بانها تتبع سياسيه تقود ابنها وقطر عندها
يقين ان هذه الدول كانت تخطط او تدبر
غزوها عسكريا فممكن الدول ديت انضم فيه
تحالف واحد اكثر من كده انه تاريخيا وعلى
مدار سنوات طويله
الدول الاصغر الدول الاصغر في مجلس الاصغر
من السعوديه طبعا اعتبر السعوديه هي
الدوله الاكبر عندها دائما عدم رغبه رغبه
في التعاون مع السعوديه لكن تخشى انت
تلاحظ سعوديه وبالتالي هي تفضل التنسيق
لكن مش الاندماج بين الكلام دا على اكثر
من مستوى مثلا على المستوى الاقتصادي لما
كان بيحاول يعملوا مجلس التعاون و عاوزين
يعملوا واحده اقتصاديه وبالتالي عمله
واحده كان فيه رفض من الدول وعشان كده
فشلت فكره العمله الخليجيه الموحده خوفا
من الكويت وخوفا من قطر وخوفا من
الامارات ودول اخرى انه يتم ابتلاع هذه
الدول عن طريق السعوديه كمان في حاله خوف
من عمليه التعاون على نطاق اوسع عسكريا
حتى لا يتم اطلاع هذه الدول المتبقي
السيطره كامله من السعوديه على حسابهم
الدليل على كده
الكلام اللي بيقولوا الامريكان من الدول
الست عندها منظومات صواريخ
وكلها منظومات صواريخ امريكيه
ومع ذلك هذه الدول تقاوم فكره بسيطه
الامريكان تقول والله من الافضل يكون ان
يكون في تنسيق ما بين الدول الست على
الاقل من حيث منظومات صواريخ من خلال غرف
تحكم واحده تدير المنظومات الست وكندا في
دوله واحده لكن هذه الدول تخشى من اجراء
هذه الخطوه وتفضل لكل دوله تجري حساباتها
بعيدا عن القياده السعوديه ده من ناحيه
الدول الخليج من ناحيه مصر يعني على
حيث القياده السعوديه يجب ان نهايه ب تشعر
بالخوف من الاطلاع السعودي بتشعر
بالحساسيه يعني عندها اعتبارات اخرى يعني
ازاي مصر تبقى تسلم ال كانت تقود السعوديه
ودي القصه معروفه ان البلدين لفتره طويله
كل بلد عندها فانهم يكونوا في تحالف واحد
تقود نصف او تقود في كمان عقبه اخرى
العقبه هي فكره اسرائيل صحيح انه فيه
تعاون بين ادوب يقوى على المستوى السياسي
بان قاده الدول العربيه خصوصا الامارات
والسعوديه واسرائيل
ولكن وطبعا قطر يعني
ولكن
الخوف او الا انه رغم وجود هذا التقارب
الا ان هذا التقارب بدرجات متفاوته بين
الدول المختلفه يعني الكويت السعوديه على
سبيل المثال موقف قطر غير موقف عمان لكن
الاهم من كده فكره انه اسرائيل موجوده
بشكل مباشر في تنسيق مباشره الضباط
الاسرائيلي يكونوا موجودين مع ضباط عرب
سواء خليجيين او خلقه او اردنيين او
مصريين ويكون التعاون دا على مستوى
القيادات الوسطى او الاقل مساله يشعر فيها
قاده الخليج
لان هذا قد يؤدي الى حاله الغضب وحاله
استثاره لدى فئات اكبر من العسكريين
وبالتالي ينعكس على الاقل او اضطرابات
داخل البيوت والاجهزه الامنيه العربيه
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر الجوله
[موسيقى]